[Applaudissements]
moi
déchirée et
il a été chiffré
alors je vais plombèrent n'est pas
plomber l'ambiance mais je voudrais dire
cette séquence à chapeau de la ferait
maintenant je voudrais la dédier un
garçon qui est venu ici qui nous a
quittés c'est nicolas ker qui étaient
venus avec arielle dombasle isa effet le
générique j'avais adoré des garçons qui
nous a quittés et cherchait qu'à chaque
fois qu'on est à des chiffres des des
repas et bien vraiment souri je lui
dédie cette séquence parce que c'est
vrai qu'à valider un très grand moment
et j'avais adoré voilà qui était venu
nous voir et qu'arielle dombasle alors
on va jouer à des jeux serait dédié
cette séquence havas graphiste parce que
là tantôt à date des années 40
auquel même toit j'ai pas vu la savane
toi tu as dit même temps c'est bien mais
ça intrigue où va jouer à déchiffrer des
jours bas
puisque jean deschênes ça non
je vous donner des chiffres vous devez
me dire à quoi ils correspondent 8
c'est bien sûr ibis c'est le nombre de
prises qu'il a fallu à jeff pour
enregistrer petits plats en équilibre
c'est le nombre de fois par jour où jean
marc et dia jeff cooke toi disons que tu
me fais mal bâtard mais c'est quoi
oui c'est plutôt facile à premier set
c'était pendant l'émission petits plats
en équilibre jeff ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher de rigoler quand laurent
mariotte utiliser le mot rebelote
regarder ça et remonter l'âge alternent
avec de la crème de potes mais replacé
la télé des années 90 et rebelote l'âge
interne avec la crème de châtaigne
[Rires]
alors au delà
et maintenant comme disent les jeunes
rebelote
mais voilà le résultat des amis à gâteau
hyper facile à faire en famille revenons
maintenant variantes au bout car
ça c'est magnifique c'est la télé des
années 90 trois pilotes
aubry doit y en aurait pu dire huit ans
de carrière aussi à oui oui c'est chiant
sic aux
8,8 en carrière fait plus que 6 mai mais
dan et non un peu plus mais oui huit ans
qu'on ait connu ouais ouais mais non
mais non huit ans sa première salle ah
oui c'est vrai ouais vous avez les
chiffres way we were toi vous l'avez
reçu sur rfm oui oui j'avais été sur rfm
j'ai été contraint mais
[Rires]
j'avais demandé j'avais demandé un
cachet même pas réussi dans la bce allez
je vous dise c'est bravo franchement
bravo je vous jure que c'est vrai nom
est franchement c'est beau parce que
voilà il peut idée même d aider des
personnes en difficulté que sa part ban
qui n'a pas aimé les animaux wallace
était au courant mais franchement alors
justement vous avez vu qu'il ya eu une
émission sur les animaux oui
oui samedi soir oui c'est quoi déjà mon
maître est une série de problèmes qu'on
a eus sur cette émission c'est que
l'échec est plus connu que
les mecs la mission l'amène bombay
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'est passé ça va ça va remonter en
audience
c'est rien ça ça peut aller très vite
d'un côté ou de l'autre la peur ni coeur
n'était pmp 1 bah oui oui mais moi je
les connaissais pas
quand il ya des chroniqueurs de tpm pays
comme à moi je le connais bien c'est
qu'il avait un petit souci les chéris 19
millions
10,9 millions c'est ton compte en banque
mois
comme quoi le compte courant je veux
dire un compas parce que dire des
grippes liu coup de coude
donc quand vous pas comme vous faites
une date où vous allez voir un
orthophoniste ou bien vous ne la fait
pas non mais c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le nouveau à chi l'ha château
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oubliez les
connaissez son papa aussi oui et bien
sûr à stéphane
méry
c'est jean pierre castagnou oui bien sûr
mais bien oui
non merci 19 millions 10,9 millions
est-ce que c'est mon nom est ce que
c'est le nombre de vues sur sa vidéo la
plus populaire avec jamel debbouze dans
l'émission plus grands gabarits
oui y'a jamais deux fois en fait oui
relevé enlevés oui bien sûr que c'est ça
même et pendant l'émission plus grand
cabaret du monde j'ai fait j'en marqué
pour mission de vannes et les invités et
ce jour là c'est au tour de jamel
debbouze 19 millions
[Musique]
j'adore ça imputant est encore traiter
tout le monde de trot du que tu peux pas
t'empêcher vraiment là plusieurs dit
devant fait les trous du coeur
même jamais wade affirme jean marc
ont en effet tout le monde lady dans
l'unité n'a pas balancé sur coécrit qui
tombe et se relève revenir
et a prôné une cause remarque
quand tu devrais faire de la radio la
télé se fait rare gens me voient leurs
montées à l'envers
indique jean-noël a rien demandé à
personne tu vois j'ai j'ai tout bien
saison 2 et les causes déroulé
tu balances passion moi je suis content
ou pas n'ont pas fait bon compte c'est
toutes écrites ou dans les livres alors
alors je me prenne ma guitare jean marc
à bondy dit tu es content
d'avoir aidé son toit
bah j'aime bien même bien votre voir
comme ça normal à cela la question ta
gueule
et avec ordres qu'on a le droit de faire
des blagues et
déjà je suis jeune donc ça me rappelle
le bon qui vont venir un jour je de
motion et aurait été beaucoup plus bon
maintenant je trouve ah ouais je trouve
break estompe ans mathieu assez
largement devancé d'un coup sûr c'est
que j'ai un peu la caution est étonnant
a été très très beau tout aussi moi y'a
pas tous il est très très beau et très
beau gosse ne touchent pas comme ça je
passe la marque est notoire un nom mais
je te le château le dit c'est bien
qu'ils soient habillés maintenant
c'est vrai que là vous voyez tabbee tout
[Rires]
ce que vous avez un don vous voilà parce
que voyez jeff par exemple il arrive
donc à ce que vous vous êtes déjà
découvert un don un truc particulier
vraiment lorsque vous êtes vous meilleur
que bon train dans un domaine à part la
médiocrité
[Rires]
est ce que vous avez vraiment un truc ou
dit ouais je suis au dessus des autres
vous moi j'ai un don surnaturel c'est
quoi ce mythe nicolas pernikoff
cyril quand est-ce que je reviens bon
wagon de ce qu'on vit
n'allait pas tenir un spectacle avec sa
paire me dire voilà on parle de 2
octobre personnes qui remplissent
décennies tout ça avec ça on ira pas ou
est-ce que vous avez un don et dur a dit
mike et moi aucun peut-être 1,9 point tu
sais pas vraiment ce que tu es incapable
mais c'est un défaut de fabrication et
en os x tu dois gère neuf santé et les
ossements humains
d'accord merci
bernard montiel 511 ça se serait su de
gagner de l'argent sans travailler c'est
vrai intérêt vous avez un don oui je
tient encore debout
mais pour attendre le mi novembre pour
une bonne intervention d'isabelle
cette année on bat des records gilles
verdez alors j'ai mon nez qui tient sans
rien pour le soutenir
saleh va bien et des auteurs sur sept
nuls
[Rires]
le cerveau le serbe milutin aussi
difficilement fiona ah non mais moi j'ai
aucun don sur l inverse de bernard c'est
que je travaille beaucoup et j'ai eu
peur aux annonces
ou non c'est vrai mais j'ai pas aucun
don
je danse très très bien des gadgets
capucines non c'est vrai vous avez des
claquettes l'assurons banon ne pas
cliquer sur moi je me bats la pac dgac
et or moi tu peux faire est de nous
montrer
[Applaudissements]
par contre est marc simon
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je demande à chaque personne peut
qualifier cette séquence par un mot
moitié dorment au jeu nantes
drôle et gênantes pathétique vous
malaise entre naufrage doivent être
surprenante lamentable
gracieux tristesse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
des chiens en battant julien et moi mais
je trouve qu'il regretterait pas grâce
notamment à lui on a des yeux
vu
l'ambiance à cette année
benjamin j'ai toujours
c'est
bar mitsva oui aussi te prends pour ça
merci s'il vous plaît quatre cent
cinquante mille c'est le nombre de
téléspectateurs qui ont assisté à la
tournée de son premier spectacle il faut
arrêter de mettre deux des deuxièmes
voilà oui oui
mais voilà 450 date de 2017 à 2019 le
spectacle de jeff a été classé numéro un
des spectacles d'humour noir
c'est énorme d euros de ca ou parce que
toi c'est vrai que tu fais pas de bruit
et itron qui tue pas mais je rigolais
fait pas beaucoup de bruit non mais oui
je suis très heureux écouter les gens se
déplacent pour venir voir un ventriloque
un must dans la phrase déjà ses armes
uniques jure c'est fou donc je
remercierai jamais assez patrick de
m'avoir mis à l'antenne et de m'avoir
permis aussi de faire tout ce que j'ai
fait de la grille que sébastien condom
erasmo patrick que j'aime voilà qui
tirait que et patrick il en a découvert
les mecs sains et c'est vrai qu'à un
ventriloque je te le dis à chaque fois
mais c'est vrai que quand on y voit la
ventriloquie tous à paris les bourses
avaient une
connotation un peu regardez là quoi
c'est devenu chez ben ouais c'est ça qui
est fou bravo moi car c'est le début
j'ai vu au zénith et c'est vraiment
impressionnant parce que tu as a means
pour combien de personnes au zénith qui
hurlent en fait le nom de jean marc barr
jean-marc presque des filles il existe
moins et c'est hallucinant de voir voilà
c'est une personne qui a à peine 1 serge
ouais
parce que le 100 m mais il est pas bien
on joue crâne mathieu mathieu sera
longtemps pas que ça peut arriver plus
vite que prévu un succès ça peut être
furtif
[Applaudissements]
vous allez encore confondu le succès
avec votre ici
durant les séries 1998 c'est l'année où
il a interprété mon fils ma bataille
dans l'émission je passe à la télé c'est
le nombre de lettres de fans qu'il a
reçus après son premier contrat varie à
huy n'ont rien de stars oui j'ai dit je
passe à la télé
donc c'est chaud passe à la télé je
passais en trois ans la monado la
vois passer oui mais bref tu la vois
tout le temps
c'est quoi je passe à la télé bon appel
c'était animé par par qui déjà bernard
montiel ces kits sa
première version avec georges beller
c'est ça ouais et après moi je suis
passé c'était gérard vivès et laetitia
nallet tout ce qui passe pu arrêter les
métiers vous laisser tenter par tout ce
qu'il fasse plus être oui byron je les
aime bien mais en plus tous ces gens qui
vont inciter souris s'était donc mais
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors que nous interpréter quoi mon fils
ma bataille de daniel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa main
mon fils ma bataille
fallait pas
nawa
[Musique]
la même regard que non mais c'est rare
qu'on change le regard un même canton
grand départ castaldi
les mecs c'est très rare non mais
j'adore cette phrase quand ils m'ont
franchement elle même rien fait si rare
que tu changes de news tu vois c'est
arrive que très rarement apparemment
germain qui les a perdu sinon voilà
c'est vrai les chéris si je vous dis 5
euros 5 euros sur pierre panne à coke et
jean-marc c'est l'argent qui l'a reçu à
ses débuts pour son premier sketch où
c'est le prix de revente du dvd de son
spectacle sur leboncoin
bon spectacle aux risques du tout
premier non ça c'est le blanc craie
droit vente sur le bon coin de se
regarder sans galles 3 5 euros livraison
la livraison est pratiquement plus cher
à la
80e pas la cote perd le contrôle à lang
s'était c'est l'ancien et figurez-vous
première qu'on a récupéré le numéro de
celui qui le mettait un magnifique et je
propose qu'on l'appelle mais on semble
pour savoir si on m'appelle monsieur on
dirait que si on arrive à avoir une
liaison téléphonique dans cette émission
c'est vrai que voilà parce que c'est
toujours compliqué ce que je peux avoir
je veux avoir la sonnerie vous plaît à
l'eau non
à l'eau on peut voir la sonnerie
pourquoi tu espères encore non mais
c'est vrai mais
chez nous c'est vraiment à l'américaine
alors allo allo allo allo oui bonjour
monsieur
oui alors c'est cyril hanouna on est
dans touche pas à mon pote direct au
cigare plus fort c'est un mec de la
famille de castanet
excusez moi non on vous appelle en fait
parce que vous avez mis le dvd de jeff
pana clock en vente sur le bon coin
selon sur leboncoin non là c'est pas le
bon coin la cellule
vous avez mis en fait le dvd de djata la
coop sur le bon coin oh oui
à 5 euros c'est pas terrible je vois que
j'ai réussi j'ai racheté au jeu c'est
pas pour moi moi je vais je m'intéresse
je crois j'ai acheté pour les
petits-enfants d'accord et j'ai relu et
je trouve que ce trop vulgaire
alors est-ce que ça fait chier alors je
ne joue pas c'est jeff et j'aurais voulu
lire amodio
monsieur je suis on est on est en direct
on avec jet et diaphane à coke et
jean-marc dieu qu'allah le vol retour
oui mais vous voyez contre lui
on voit pas on voit pas les lèvres du
raid entre ennemis nantes
se trouver les bons mots que je ne
surtout pas au complet quoique en gros
mon fou diront certains le veulent et
elles nous font les enfants et le chat
botté ipa jouet cassé le cul avec casino
châtel
ça c'est une émission familiale
qu'est ce qui se passe quand je vois pas
je veux pas combien d'enfants tentent
des choses pareilles alors et il y en a
quand il ya des gens qui disent que
c'est un peu cru qu est ce que vous leur
répondez à ces [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
disent que c'est un petit peu plus
monsieur si je peux tout perdre oui
c'était une blague à monsieur oui de la
part de deuil a paru être que les gens
et l'humain dans le cul c'est un puzzle
[Rires]
de sa poule mais qu'il a fait parler sa
nos cieux alors mais qu'est ce que vous
dites à des gens qui sont un peu bas qui
dit ça c'est non je sais pas mais voilà
on en parle on en parle dans le
spectacle à la voilà on parle de ça à la
fin du spectacle où jean marc dickey un
peu triste qu'on le cantonne que à des
vérités voilà le jeu c'est pas vrai j'ai
invite tous les gens nés à payer quand
même oui les gens à venir voir le
spectacle en entier vous verrez qu'à pas
que tient sur monsieur c'est pas de
prénom monsieur à qui revend le dvd le
gars ouais c'est quoi votre prénom je
m'appelle patrick patrick comme un peu
le même patrick sébastien
[Applaudissements]
jeff viens de parler de toi et un
instant il disait que il voulait voilà
il disait que tu l'avais vu des vues
patrick j'ai eu allons sûrement bobo
jambes à de gros bijoux aussi moi je lui
pose la grenouille qui casse les
couilles la sens est ouest et dans celle
de mes couilles jean marc et jean marc
qui sera pas la droit mais patrick
sébastien sera avec nous demain
patrick sébastien a
adoré c'était très bon ça ou pas illégal
ou comment on va pouvoir passer des
coups de fil dans cette émission
ça commence à ressembler à quelque chose
très bientôt sur tf1 un maillot c'est
vrai qu'ils ont décollé au c'est pas mal